Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Buried.
Now, we're about to begin chapter four
and things are really really dire.
To recap - we're going back up to the command center
to open the hangar bay doors which
I don't know why we didn't do
but we didn't do that.
*reading* The ride up the elevator is tense.
I take a series of deep breaths, doing everything i can
to stay in control.
Amy has gone back to her feet, but her head is pressed
against the elevator wall as she supresses a series of sobs.
I find myself trying to remember the way those creatures
looked but my mind seems to shudder the effort.
*continues reading*
*reading* I ready the rifle, suddenly certain that there are more
of those creatures waiting for us in the hallway of the Second Level.
But the way is clear, allowing us to haul ass to the command center.
Once again I find myself staring at the screen
that shows my ruined worksite.
"Okay, okay," Amy says, typing commands rapidly.
*continues reading*
Well, I- you know what- I'm- I don't think I need to know
what happens in twenty minutes.
I think I know what happens in twenty minutes.
*continues reading*
Well, damn, that was a quick go of things.
Oh this is not gonna be good.
I hope we find Marcus' body
'cause maybe they went after him-
considering that he was alive maybe they went after him
and didn't decide to bother us.
*reading* As the elevator doors open, we peer out,
looking to see if the creatures are still in the area.
But it's all clear.
When Amy looks at me, her eyes are clear and strong.
"Marcus wasn't entirely wrong," Amy says as we start walking
back towards the hangar.
*continues reading*
See, why would you be to blame?
I mean you're doing a science but-
you didn't know.
*continues reading*
"Switcherland"
Oh shit
That's not good
*hisses*
yeeesh
*reading* The creature is about ten feet away
and coming in quickly, so I do the first thing that comes to mind.
I drop to the ground, making myself a smaller target,
and raise the rifle.
I'm not sure if I should just unload on the bastard,
or try to be choosy with my shots to weaken it
or at least slow it down.
Shoot to weaken.
Obviously we're not gonna be able to kill these things.
That's why I shot at the things before because I KNOW
that it can be slowed down but not killed.
*continues reading*
I guess I could distract it?
It seems to be very important right now to... conserve my ammo so,
if I can distract it then I can get outta here.
*continues reading*
Oh, I'm /pleased/ at that!
Oh, that's a /good/ thing.
Oh ho okay.
Alright then.
Great.
Hoo boy.
*reading* The room seems to be an assortment of old pipes and tanks.
I assume some of them run further down into the other areas
of the facility.
With the creature on my tail, I dash into the maze of metal,
hoping to lose it.
It's definitely having a harder time squeezing through than I am,
and that slows it down.
*continues reading*
Let's see.
I'm gonna run as fast as I can.
Because, frankly, I need to get there before they close.
But maybe, ugh, I only had six minutes to get in
and that's probably like four minutes ago.
I gotta GO.
I gotta book it.
*continues reading*
Yop, let's do that.
Let's do that. Let's do that.
*reading* I burst back into the large room and see Amy
still working on the computer terminal by the hangar doors.
"You okay?" I ask Amy.
I can clearly see her battling for control of her faculties.
Steeled determination winds out and she gives a grim nod.
*continues reading*
I've only got two shots left...
now would be the time to use 'em.
*hisses*
urghhhhh
Two bullets, two monsters, okay!
I'll take that chance.
*continues reading*
Let's see.
Oh boy.
My guess is that touching this thing is probably not a good idea.
I'm gonna try to get away.
*continues reading*
*sighs*
What's Amy gonna do, Amy doesn't have anything.
She's gotta open those doors.
Let's punch the fucker.
Let's just punch it.
*continues reading*
Good man, Dennis.
I'm glad you're safe Dennis. Jesus.
Thought he was dead.
*continues reading*
Let's see.
How much longer, Amy?
Fucking Marcus.
*continues reading*
Dennis already has a shotgun.
He's good with that. That's his baby.
I'll take the handgun.
Yeah.
*continues reading*
If- If we slow them down there's a chance...
I'm not gonna make the mistake- oh shit. I don't know.
Should we? It- It looks like- oh fuck.
So the terminal is disabled, there's no way shooting at them
is gonna give us enough time, like, to close it.
So I say we just go for it.
*continues reading*
Best not to waste ammo, I guess. I learned that lesson.
*reading* The room is enormous... so large that to call it a room seems silly.
A large concrete floor stretches out below an expansive
lofted ceiling.
The area is mostly empty, except for one side
which has rows and rows of metal barrels.
Back on the far wall is a lit area
that seems to expose more rooms, labs and machinery.
*continues reading*
I'M gonna keep shooting to cover the others.
Dennis can't run, he's still injured.
I HAVE to remember that.
*continues reading*
Dennis and Amy get in that fucking door.
Push him out of the way. Gotta push him down.
No time to call out to him.
*continues reading*
I'm gonna shoot Dennis' hand off.
Dennis...
I'm not gonna lose Dennis. I'm not gonna lose Dennis.
I'm gonna take action here.
Imma shoot your f... sorry.
Sorry.
Sorry Dennis.
*continues reading*
End of chapter four.
There is NO WAY I am NOT gonna shoot off his hand.
Like fuck no.
If YOU are one of my good friends,
at least in a survival scenario,
you're one of my good friends
I am NOT gonna let you risk being torn to pieces in front of my eyes
when I could- I could fricking shoot you in the hand
and...
oh man.
oh boy.
And it's a good thing I had the handgun
because that's the only way that I could've been accurate.
Okay so, let's do a postmortem of all these different things.
"Self Control." -players shot to weaken the creature, not to kill it
because there was no point in killing it
I learned that I couldn't kill it from me shooting at it before
so there was no point in me even trying.
"Keep Them at Bay."
Uh, seven- forty one percent players distracted the creature
instead of shooting it.
Again, can't waste my ammo. I didn't have any left.
"Weapon of Choice", preferably, Dennis was shotgun man.
And uh, you know, maybe he can use a shotgun with uh
a stup arm and another good hand.
But, y'know, I did what I had to do there.
And especially on the "Judgement Call"
he was dangling in air.
They were looming over him. How in the world
would he have gotten away from that.
There's no way an injured man like that
would've gotten away, he would've been killed.
Or maybe he wouldn't have. I have no idea.
I'm not gonna take that risk, y'know what I mean?
I'm just not gonna do that.
So I had to take the shot.
But either way, that's- that's how I did there, so...
Let me know how you did if you're playing this game for yourselves
and let me know how you think I did.
And reasoning for going one way or another
because most of these choices I've found
are an even fifty fifty split.
So thanks again so much for watching
and as always, I will see YOU in the next video.
Buh bye!